Now that the year's horror releases are all
but set in stone, film studios are looking
ahead to draw audiences to theaters with a
brand new round of exciting trailers.
What treats did September deliver?
Here's a roundup of all the best trailers
from September 2018.
First Man
Apollo 11 may have put a man on the moon,
but First Man is putting the humanity in the
moon landing.
The latest trailer for Universal's dramatic
biopic about Neil Armstrong plays out under
stock audio of JFK's "moon speech," as Ryan
Gosling's Armstrong contemplates everything
he's about to leave behind.
It's a pretty moving trailer, and it serves
as the perfect last-minute hype-builder for
a movie that's already seeing an overwhelmingly
positive response from early screenings.
Get ready for the ride of your life when First
Man touches down October 12th.
Hunter Killer
Gary Oldman is a true chameleon, one of those
actors who can transition seamlessly from
an Oscar-winning portrayal of Winston Churchill
to being the voice of a house in a silly Netflix
movie.
"The walls are treated with a layer of smartpaint and
reinforced with nano materials.
Hun?
The walls are treated with a layer of smartpaint and
reinforced with okay, I got it."
What will he bring to Lionsgate's submarine
action thriller Hunter Killer?
Only God knows.
The plot of the movie follows Gerard Butler's
Captain Glass, a submarine commander who's
on a mission to rescue the president of Russia.
How many bad guys are they going to have to
fight through to get him back?
Gary Oldman knows!
"Everyone!"
The trailer is heavy on the torpedoes and
light on anything else, but Hunter Killer
looks like a fun action-packed blockbuster.
Take a look on October 26th.
The Girl in the Spider's Web
Each new trailer for The Girl in the Spider's
Web unravels that web a little more, offering
up new plot details and tantalizing glimpses
of the action to come.
The film is an adaptation of the fourth book
in the Millennium series, which sees Lisbeth
Salander on the run from the NSA after hacking
into their servers.
She'll have to team up with her old buddy
Mikael Blomkvist to sort out a brand new conspiracy.
The trailer also reveals that Salander will
have a run-in with her estranged sister.
Expect plenty of snow, leather, and hacking
when The Girl in the Spider's Web spins into
theaters on November 9th.
The Ballad of Buster Scruggs
When it was first announced, The Ballad of
Buster Scruggs was supposed to be the first
TV series written and developed by the Coen
brothers.
It's since been changed to an anthology film,
but the underlying premise remains the same:
it's an offbeat comedy Western that was pieced
together over the past 25 years from scraps
of stories that the brothers just had no idea
what else to do with.
That may sound a little absurd, but if anyone
can pull it off it's Joel and Ethan Coen,
the duo behind similarly absurd cult classics
such as O Brother, Where Art Thou? and Raising
Arizona.
"Son, you got a panty on your head."
Look for The Ballad of Buster Scruggs on Netflix
and in select theaters on November 16th.
Fantastic Beasts: The Crimes of Grindelwald
In The Crimes of Grindelwald, Newt Scamander
is back on a brand new quest at the behest
of Albus Dumbledore - the villainous Grindelwald
has magically escaped from magic prison, and
Dumbledore needs Newt to bring him back in…
with magic!
Johnny Depp stars as Grindelwald, who's using
his free time to recruit an army of followers
to help him rule the world.
Great Gellert!
The stakes have never been higher, and you
can watch it all unfold when Fantastic Beasts:
The Crimes of Grindelwald apparates into theaters
on November 16th.
Creed II
The Rocky franchise has always been less about
boxing and more about breaking the audience's
hearts in between slick training montages,
and it looks like we're going to get a double
dose of both with Creed II.
This time, Adonis will be squaring off against
Viktor Drago, the son of Ivan Drago, who killed
Apollo Creed in Rocky IV.
Now, the next generation of fans gets to watch
the next generation of big-screen boxers duke
it out for the heavyweight title.
Michael B. Jordan, Tessa Thompson, and ol'
Sly Stallone are returning to their roles
from the first Creed, with a special appearance
by Dolph Lundgren as the Siberian Bull himself,
Ivan Drago.
Step into the ring on November 21st.
Mary Poppins Returns
The original Mary Poppins is a childhood classic,
a magical romp through the imagination led
by Julie Andrews.
2018's Mary Poppins Returns won't be a remake,
but a direct sequel to the 1964 original.
A new tragedy summons Mary Poppins back into
the lives of the Banks kids from the original,
who are now adults.
They'll all set off on a new adventure that
teaches these grumpy grown-ups that getting
older doesn't necessarily mean you have to
lose your sense of childhood wonder.
Ben Whishaw and Emily Mortimer play the adult
Michael and Jane Banks, and the ageless Mary
Poppins will be played by Emily Blunt.
Look for it on December 19, just in time for
Christmas.
Holmes and Watson
After months of hearing about the upcoming
Will Ferrell and John C. Reilly team-up comedy
Holmes and Watson, expectations were pretty
high.
This was supposed to be Step Brothers, but
with mysteries.
"What are you doing?"
I'm burying you.
I'm alive!
I'm alive.
Shh waking the neighbors, shut up."
Instead of all that, the trailer for Holmes
and Watson just gives us two and a half minutes
of vaguely comedic… stuff.
To be fair, this is just the trailer.
It could get better.
Comedies are particularly hard to market,
so there's still hope for Holmes and Watson
to turn out to be legitimately funny.
We'll be able to finally solve this mystery
when Holmes and Watson hits theaters on December
21st.
Bumblebee
Cars and trucks are cool, sure - but do you
know what's cooler?
Cars and trucks with feelings.
As the Transformers franchise's first prequel,
Bumblebee is shifting gears for a more down-to-earth
experience that looks like a far cry from
the city-smashing extravaganzas offered by
the main run of Transformers films.
Y'know, stuff like this:
In the newest trailer, Bumblebee deepens his
emotional bond with young Charlie as they're
both caught up in a war that's beyond their
control.
It's like Herbie: Reloaded, if Herbie was
reloaded with actual bullets.
Look for Bumblebee in theaters on December
21st.
Dark Phoenix
20th Century Fox has gone down the Dark Phoenix
road once before, and it turned out to be
a very dark road indeed.
2006's X-Men: The Last Stand marked a notoriously
troubled end to the original X-Men cinematic
trilogy, and it made a mess of one of the
most beloved character arcs in X-Men comics
history: The Dark Phoenix Saga.
Based on the trailer for Dark Phoenix, it
looks like the story may finally get the live-action
adaptation it deserves.
Throughout the trailer, we see Jean slowly
turning to the dark side after absorbing the
Phoenix Force during a freak solar flare accident
in space.
It seems to hit all the right notes, and you
can look for Dark Phoenix to hit theaters
on June 7, 2019
Captive State
From Rupert Wyatt, director of Rise of the
Planet of the Apes, Captive State is an upcoming
sci-fi thriller about a world that's been
occupied by an extraterrestrial force.
In exchange for peace and prosperity for all
mankind, the aliens only want one thing: total
domination.
Those darn aliens!
"Peace among worlds, Rick."
The teaser trailer for Captive State shows
a ton of promise, focusing mainly on the film's
hellish dystopian imagery while a voiceover
repeats the words "Give thanks."
Moonlight's Ashton Sanders stars alongside
John Goodman and Vera Farmiga, and Captive
State is slated for a March 2019 release.
Captain Marvel
Ever since that end-credits scene of Avengers:
Infinity War, fans have been clamoring for
more glimpses of Brie Larson as Captain Marvel.
Now, we finally got our wish in the form of
a full-length trailer.
Was the wait worth it?
Yeah, kind of!
Brie Larson does plenty of Captain Marvely
things in the trailer, like jumping around,
and being powerful.
What else happens?
Glad you asked!
First, she crash lands in a Blockbuster video
store, because this movie takes place in that
distant part of the past known as the 1990s.
Even Captain Marvel can't figure out what
that place is.
She's so out of touch with the world that
she punches someone's grandma.
What'd you think she was, Carol?
A Skrull?
This trailer does build a lot of expectations
for the movie, and we honestly can't wait
to see it when Captain Marvel hits theaters
on March 8th, 2019.